قالت محكمه العدل الدوليه اليوم الاثنين
ان هولندا وكندا طلبتا مقاضات النظام
السوري امامها بتهمه ارتكابه جرائم تعذيب
واضافت المحكمه في بيان ان كندا وهولندا
اتهمتا نظام السوري بارتكاب انتهاكات لا
حصر لها للقانون الدولي بدءا من عام 2011
على اقل تقديرا ومنها المعامله والظروف
غير الانسانيه في اماكن الاحتجاز والاخفاء
القصري واستخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه
وطلبتات خارج رئات طارئه لحمايه المعرضين
لخطر التعذيب
انضم الينا من لندن
المحامي المختص بالقانون الدولي اهلا بك
السيد حسب القانون الدولي ما الذي يعني
هذا التحرك الذي اقدمت عليه كندا وهولندا
جزيلا اولا ما تم اعلانه رسميا اليوم هو
انه هولندا وكندا قد تقدمت بطلب مشترك
امام محكمه العدل الدوليه
بسبب انتهاك الاتفاقيات الدوليه وخاصه
اتفاقيه ضد التعذيب وهذا يعني ان هناك
مسؤوليه للدوله وهاتان الدولتان تحولان
محاسبه السوري على انتهاكاتها لهذه
الاتفاقيه والان الملف اصبح على مستوى
محكمه العدل الدوليه ما الخطوه المرتقبه
الان من قبل المحكمه
رايناه حتى اللحظه هو ان طلب التقديم قد
تم علنا وهذه العمليه برمتها بدات العامه
2020 حقيقه عندما بادرت هولندا بالبدء
بمفاوضات مع جمهوريه سوريا العربيه كما هو
مطلوب منها وفق
الاتفاقيه وانضمت الحكومه الكنديه في 2021
الى هذه الاجراءات للاسف عمليه التفاوض
لحل
الخصومه هذه لم تنجح مما ادى الى رفع
القضيه امام محكمه العدل الدوليه كما ان
هناك نقطه اخرى مهمه ينبغي ايضاحها بناء
على البيان الصحفي من محكمه العدل الدولي
ان كلا البلدين طلب تدابير مؤقته استنادا
الى النظام الد اخلي للمحكمه لالزامي
سوريا بمعليها من التزامات وفق الاتفاقيه
وهل القضيه الان يكفي تقديم الادله فقط
لاثبات هذه التهمه ام ان الامر يستوجب
يستوجب تعاون من قبل سوريا النظام السوري
وذاك عدد من الاسئله ما تزال مطروحه اولا
العمليه تم البدء بها الان والامر متروك
للمحكمه لتقرر ما هي الاجراءات التاليه
وما هو الاطار الزمني للتحرك وكما ترون من
البيان الصحفي الذي صدر عن كندا وهولندا
البيان يشير الى النوع الادله التي
اليهما بناء على هيئه التحقيق
الامميه وايضا هيئه التحقيق لجمع الادله
المستقله الامميه اذا الادله المقدمه ادله
دامغه تفيد
بمقامت به الصوره هل سوريا ستتعاون علينا
ان نتذكر حقيقه ان ان محكمه العدد الدوليه
هي اعلى جهاز قضائي تابع للامم المتحده
وكاي دوله عضو في الامم المتحده مطلوب
منها ان تتعاون لانها صادقت على الاتفاقيه
الدوليه
وبذلك سمحت محكمه العدل الدوليه ان يكون
لها اختصاص وولايه قانونيه لتستمر بهذه
الاجراءات شكرا جزيلا لك
المحامي المختص بالقانون الدولي حدث من
لندن